i'm very much looking forward to this
video because today's topic is both
quite juicy but also highly educational
an inspiration for today's topic was
coming from a harvard business
review article that was reading the
article is called how consultants
project expertise and learn at the same
time
i will link the article in the video
description i do think it is quite
insightful it'll pretty much ask the
question
are all consultants con man are they
sincere what tactics do they apply
to potentially create an impression from
the client that is not accurate and as
an introduction to the topic i want to
read out to you one paragraph of the
article
the challenge with effective consulting
is that it depends on in-depth
situational knowledge that consultants
simply can't have
when they start an assignment what's
more they may not yet be completely
clear on what the client
who's paying top dollars and expects
results immediately
really once so consultants must rapidly
and discreetly
gain knowledge of the client's business
while simultaneously giving an
impression of competence
and self-confidence we call this channel
learning credibility tension and this is
indeed a challenge that you almost
always face as a consultant if you start
on a new project
because on the one hand the client
expects you to be super competent
highly knowledgeable on a topic from day
one from the very first day
you set foot at the client's office but
on the other hand you might be young you
might come
fresh out of university maybe you did a
similar project in the past
for sure you do not know in detail the
client's current processes
so how can you be perceived as credible
and confident by the client if
actually you are not if actually you
might need a couple of weeks a couple of
months
to get up to speed to really get all the
knowledge and learnings that you need to
really come to a great and valuable
recommendation for the client so this is
the topic we're going to talk about
today so welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning
my name is heinrich i'm a former
strategy consultant and i want to help
you to become successful
in the first years of your career now
before we jump into this i know that
this topic is a little bit controversial
and after watching this video some of
you might really indeed think that
consulting
is a con man job this is not really what
i want to say here with this video this
is
not my position and i also want to open
with a little disclaimer that all the
things that i will talk about now
are to my knowledge not officially
endorsed
by any large consulting firm for sure
not by the employers that i worked for
in the past and these things are also
not
part of any official training
curriculums of any of these large
consulting firms that i'm aware of this
is
rather practical street smartness type
of knowledge type of tips
that you will pick up by doing this job
over time so let's start by putting
ourselves into the shoes of a consultant
you're sitting at the client in your
first one or two weeks of the project
and you need to learn more you need to
learn more about the client's business
the clients
industry what exactly the problem is
that you need to solve how the client's
processes work
and so on now what can you do of course
you can just blatantly ask the client
what does this mean how does this work
how's this supposed to go
so if you do this if you ask these type
of direct questions you will often get
not so nice
answers from the clients they might say
well this is why i hired consultants for
them to give me the answers
i shouldn't train you you should know
these things
why are we paying you so much money if
you're not even aware of these vedic
things of our business of our industry
and so on and trust me that these are
not some theoretical considerations you
hear
things like that all the time on
projects
these things happen quite frequently and
indeed a partner i worked with in the
past once told me
well heinrich you know consulting is
like close quarter combat
you really need to be careful need to
watch every step behind
every corner behind every door there
might be danger
be careful so it might be fair to argue
that as a consultant
often you need to fake it till you make
it in the first weeks or in the first
months you somehow need to pretend to be
knowledgeable to be an expert until you
really build up that knowledge over time
and this is now where the juicy part of
this video begins because now i want to
share
four of these sneaky tactics that you
could employ as a consultant
to create exactly this impression and
again i do not say that every consultant
is using techniques like this and also
do not necessarily endorse to behave in
this way
but let's just say that tactics like
this can be quite helpful in certain
situations
and the first tactic is to leverage the
fact that you as a consultant have an
opportunity
that many other employees of the company
do not have and this is that you as part
of your project
will very often be able to talk to lots
of different people at the client
from lots of different departments and
by that you will collect
lots of information the probably many
employees will not be able to have
if they just work on one specific task
in one specific
department for their whole career so
often by talking to one client you will
pick up some industry trends some
certain specific information on what is
going on
in the company the probably another
client of yours another employee of the
company
is not really aware of so the next time
you then talk to this other person at
the client you can then selectively
share
some of the information that you got
from the first client and by that
because
this other client might not be aware of
that he or she will then often perceive
feels very competent very
well informed that you really know your
things if you tell him information about
their company that even they do not know
and indeed there's this sarcastic saying
that consultants just
borrow your watch to tell you the time
and while of course this oversimplifies
it i do think that there is some truth
to that
in the sense that this works up to the
highest levels often after a project in
the end than if you really present
your final results to the board to the
sea level
in your recommendation it will not be
unusual that at least some of the
recommendations that you make will be
ideas that you more or less directly
derive
from information that you got from other
people working in the organization from
people really working in the machine
room that just shared some ideas with
you and what the company needs to do to
improve
and to now not digress too far from the
topic of this video i do not want to
debate the merits of this
i do think though that there is an
argument to be made that even if
consultants do that there still can be a
significant
value add in the way that consultants do
this but again let's maybe park this for
another video
the second sneaky tactic that i want to
talk about today
is just how you frame your information
and specifically to frame information
that you have as your very own
experiences
so let's imagine that you indeed do some
research on the client on the industry
before you start the project and you
maybe read a book or report about
specific things
maybe you even talked to some experts
some other people some senior partners
so you do
know some things about the topic that
now you need to work on but of course
the problem here is if you're having a
debate with a client and you want to
share some pieces of information
and you just say oh yeah i read this in
a book or i read this in a report
of course this will often not be very
convincing this will not really portray
you
as a big expert on a certain topic so
instead you can
frame this as your own experiences you
can say oh yes last time i worked on
this
this is how we did it you can say from
my experience
this is how this is handled this is how
usually this works
this is what other companies in this
field do and this frames you as not only
being book smart it's not only being a
student who read about a certain topic
in the past but as being a practitioner
is being an expert who has done similar
things in the past
has worked on these specific topics on
prior engagement on prior jobs or
whatever
my third little sneaky tactic is on how
to frame questions
and actually this i picked up in one of
my very first internships
i was working with a project lead and
she always seemed super
confident she always seemed like she
really wouldn't know her things so one
day i just asked her as an intern you
know how do you do this you always seem
so confident though clearly these topics
need to be new to you at least to some
extent as way
so i asked her how do you do this and
she indeed shared one little tactic with
me that i really found helpful and
frankly also applied several times
myself then afterwards and she told me
you know whenever a client uses a term
that you do not understand or say
something that is not really clear to
you instead of asking
what does this mean what does this term
mean instead of asking this because
these questions of course potentially
make you look ignorant
instead rather ask what do you mean with
this term
what does this mean to you what exactly
do you mean if you say this
because what this implies is that not
only you understand the general meaning
of what this person was talking about
but you even have this higher more
abstract knowledge
that you are aware that not everybody in
every company
is using this term in the very same way
so now you want to know specifically
how this client and this company is
using this
so you completely turn around the frame
from you have no idea at all about what
this person is talking about to you
really completely understanding this but
now you really want to understand
how exactly this is meant this is to be
understood
at this company for this client for this
person so the fourth tactic is maybe the
most
sneaky one and i even asked myself
whether i should include it but i want
to be
open and transparent with you because i
do know that some people do this but
reflect on this for yourself and only
use at your own discretion and this
tactic can help you to be perceived as
intelligent
of course the client when he or she
hires consultants
especially when the client hires mbb
consultants everybody
knows what the fees are for these type
of professionals
they expect to work with highly
intelligent people and so of course it
might help you if you are indeed
perceived
to be intelligent but how can you signal
that you are
intelligent and indeed at least from my
experience one of the strongest
signals that always have a very strong
effect is
mental math if you are really good at
mental math everybody will think that
you are highly intelligent interestingly
this is not only true for clients but
for your own team for your partner your
project lead you work with this way and
of course ideally you really are
good with mental math this is really
easy to you and then you can indeed
impress people just by doing some crazy
calculations
in your head so what do you do actually
your mental math is
really bad you're just not good at all
of it so what you could do is when you
prepare for a meeting
and when you know that you will present
for instance some parts of a document or
maybe a whole document
some pages of a powerpoint presentation
then already think about okay are there
some pages where there are numbers on
them
where potentially you could do some
little calculations on your presentation
that would seem quite impressive because
then what you can do is that you can
fake the mental math so before you walk
into the meeting
you think of a calculation you already
calculate the result with
excel over the calculator and then you
walk into the meeting you present the
document
and then live on the spot you pretend
that you're calculating something saying
ah okay so if you multiply this by this
and then you divide it by this then this
is the number that you will get so again
yes this is probably more than just
sneaky so take responsibility for your
own actions and decide whether you
really want to do this or not so now
reflecting on these tactics and i also
want to make it clear that these tactics
are not only relevant for consultants
but also for temporary workers for
freelancers for other professional
advisors
these are just things that are to some
extent necessary to bridge
the so-called learning credibility
tangent that the article is describing
to bridge this tangent
the from the very beginning you just
need to be perceived as credible if you
want to succeed in your job but at the
same time you also need the time to get
some learning from the client to really
get up to speed and really understand
what this whole project is all supposed
to be about
so i'd really love to hear your
perspective on this topic how do you see
this that you already apply
similar strategies what is your
experience with this as you know i will
do my very best to answer
every single comment that you write and
yes every comment that you do write also
helps me with the youtube algorithm if
you want to continue your learning
journey with this channel from learning
check out my other video on how
consultants solve
tough problems for their clients i will
link the video somewhere about fear
trust it will be worth it check it out
and if you took any value at all out of
this video please hit the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also hit
the subscribe button to stay up to date
on all my content i release new videos
every single saturday also have an
instagram my handle is firm learning so
follow me there to see even more from me
and indeed also have
a firm learning newsletter sign up link
in the video description and i want to
end by saying thank you to all the
members of this channel you're really
making a big contribution to the course
of this channel
thank you so much for your support so if
you watched until the end also let me
know in the comments i very much
appreciate that thank you for your
support good weekend to all of you
see you back next saturday this is heine
from from learning all the best to you
and bye bye